it's come out that president Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen also represents Fox
News host Sean Hannity he represents
Sean Hannity yeah apparently Cohen would
pay women 130,000 dollars to watch
Hannity show that was the whole idea
that's how they yeah that's the scandal
did you all see former FBI director
James Comey had a two hundred a two-hour
interview last night on 20/20 you saw
that yeah I'm just gonna take your
silence as a yes but watch that what's
going on in this country what's that
what a huge he was huge I was like nah
didn't we see it I was watching ballers
did you know this more people watch the
interview with porn star stormy Daniels
than the interview with James Comey yeah
that's be story yeah and for some reason
her videos on pornhub are way more
popular
sir it's like you have a tick you got a
watch he's like he's hiccupping this guy
right in his interview he was excited to
see me he just can't help himself
hunters are looking for him at night
anyway in his interview James Comey says
he believes that the Russians may have
damaging information on President Trump
yeah yet for example the Russians
claimed to have video footage of
everything Trump has ever said on
television they have that now someone up
there has it it's spreading around all
right
Royal Wedding coming soon that's pretty
exciting yeah there you go yeah did you
know this Megan markle's nephew is
creating a strain of marijuana called
the Markel sparkle yeah yeah the
marijuana is so strong it renders you as
useless as a member of the royal family
[Applause]
we fled to England right we O'Brien's we
didn't flee anything we got our asses
kicked out of Ireland scientists this is
crazy scientists are predicting that in
a few years we will be able to smell the
TV shows we watch smell them yeah yeah
this is good news for everybody and
every single show except Dog the Bounty
Hunter that would be will be the one
we're probably did show it well you have
a pleasant odor Andi why thank you yeah
yes America should smell me yeah yeah
okay
you are like a Yankee Candle it's great
you